[Music]
hit and run had to go up this weekend
against the Expendables to worry you at
all going up against Expendables well
look I saw Expendables one there's a
scene where Sly Stallone comes into a
garage this is in the original this is
the original on him and he comes into a
garage and Mickey Rourke's in there and
he and sly pulls his shirt off and gets
on a motorcycle and he's like straddling
the gas tank of a motorcycle with his
top off and then Mickey Rourke takes his
top off and then gets his tattoo gun and
he gets behind him and he just starts
tattooing slides back like really you're
doing this well cuz they're both they
both greasy and their shirts are off in
there on a motorcycle in Italy this is
really a scene from the first ever touch
me it's basically because he's obviously
turned on right turned on by what you're
describing then it confuse me it's the
it's this is the gayest scene I've ever
seen in a movie and I've seen gay sex
so you find that they would have to top
that scene in Expendables 2 and I'm just
not man enough to see that like what are
they on snowmobiles four of them greased
up to branding each other